tout de suite on direct paula slayer
journalistes pour rt internationale en
direct de tel-aviv
bonsoir paula merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes notre correspondante sur place
à deux jours de l'échéance pour former
un gouvernement
rien ne semble joué n'est ce pas
effectivement vigueur en israël a peu
changé la donne en matière de politique
la pièce mercredi le la vie qui fait que
je suis là pitch est l'opposition
gratuit avant donc ce mercredi
je suis la doit présenter à reouven
rivlin et le majorité de coalition pour
le moment effectivement il ya une
majorité puis l'a 61 61 députés sur 120
à la knesset
et si la collation tient toujours
mercredi alors il pourra dire au
président je te former le prochain
gouvernement
mais effectivement tout n'est pas joué
car le ministre actuel péniche netanyahu
devra quitter le pouvoir que mardi
prochain
donc ce que la semaine prochaine en
martyr que le scénario sera enterré
car au cours de ce laps de temps si je
vous dis n'importe lequel des 61 membres
de cette nouvelle coalition
l'abandonnent alors il n'y aura plus de
majorité et le pays devra se rendre à
nouveau aux urnes
[Musique]
il a beaucoup de réunions en coulisses
de winnie sous deux ministres et
potentiels établissant les demain de ce
qu'il souhaite et elle a pu le dirigeant
de l'opposition
yaïr lapid etc
j'aurais tout cela afin de conserver
cette majorité de 61 sur 120 sièges
alors des rivaux on peut lire
idéologiquement très disparates qui se
rapprochent ils n'ont qu'un but en fait
déloger bayemi netanyahu
effectivement ce sont des alliés très
étrange nabli checked l'opposition est
au centre gauche de l'échiquier
politique israélien et il sait avec
quelle un chef de la droite
naftali bennet chef du parti yami no 6
ce qui signifie parti de droite s'est
également l'ancien ministre de la
défense se dit sereine sein de cette
coalition
on trouve également les partis arabes
israéliens dans les angles naftali
bennett qui est à droite ça et les
partis arabes à gauche n'ont absolument
rien en commun notamment on regarde ce
récent conflit entre le hamas et israël
il tenait à l'époque je suis belle et
nette à l'époque des propos très âpres
sur la qualité arabe et déclamatoire
vouloir former un gouvernement avec eux
donc effectivement des alliances est
très étrange qui montre bien le niveau
des divisions au sein du pays
et comme vous l'avait bien dit ce qui
est laid et rassemble c'est l'opposition
à netanyahu
mais tout cela pourrait ne pas suffire à
maintenir cette coalition promeneuse qui
avait des joueurs l'un des pronostics
en israël c'est que même si la semaine
prochaine
ils réussissent à former un gouvernement
alors il ne durera sont deux fois plus
longtemps que quelques mois du fait de
ses vues politiques extrêmement
disparates
après justement c'est cette alliance un
peu contre nature by nintendo a mis en
garde contre un danger pour la sécurité
de l'état d'israël
il a parlé d' ailleurs d' arnaque du
siècle cette alliance met-elle vraiment
en danger l'état hébreu est voué u2 ou
cela dépendra qui lui demande s'il
demande à certains israéliens ils se
sentent trahis par naftali bennett qui
rejoint une coalition de centre gauche
si on demande des personnes plutôt à
gauche
elle trouve fantastique que netanyahu
doivent enfin quitter le pouvoir
et là je pense que oui vers la piste
naphtaline à ont trouvé un accord avec
eux deux ans au pouvoir pour naftali
bennet puis deux ans avec air lapide les
gens pensent que l'umq m
cela sera le gouvernement dont israël a
besoin cela dépend donc actions de la
plupart des israéliens sont d'accord
pour dire que quatre élections en espace
mais deux ans c'est trop s'ils ne tient
pas jusqu'à mardi de la semaine
prochaine
alors il devrait y avoir des nouvelles
élections donc seulement ne soutient pas
cette nouvelle coalition mais je pense
que la majorité des israéliens ne
soutiendrait pas l'idée d'une cinquième
élection c'est le raisonnement qu'a
avancé un aphte ali bennett pour
expliquer cette pollution dix ans
sortons de cette crise politique
mettons un terme à ces élections
récurrente pour la mélamine et année où
peut-il encore s'en sortir dans le
contexte actuel s'il écoute c'est
effectivement une possibilité
cette création qui se forme quand on rit
pourrait excuser ils ont 61 sièges il
pourrait en être ainsi peña mines
britannia où tu n'as pas de majorité
avec simplement 50 personnes
j'avais alors il y aura de nouvelles
élections après si si la coalition ne
tient pas et dans une interview pourrait
réussir à former une coalition
la seule manière de pouvoir être réélu
pour payer mon yahoo serait de nouvelles
sélections car il apparaît s'est reformé
de nouvelles positions et il a tenu un
discours hier soir avertissant que cette
coalition était très dangereuse car elle
a lié des éléments de gauche et de
droite
il a expliqué que ce gouvernement je ne
pourrais pas prendre de décisions sur
des décisions polémiques tels que le
processus de paix du fait de leur
différence c'est le nouveau gouvernement
alors il serait plus susceptible de se
concentrer sur la sortie de lakovic
l'économie et le maintien du cessez le
feu entre hamas et israël
il ne serait selon benyamin nétanyahou
est pas capable en 2 traiter des sujets
difficiles du fait de la disparité est
des points de vue au sein de cette
coalition qui espère être le nouveau
gouvernement
merci pour la seigneur journalistes pour
rt internationale en direct de tel aviv